and ponder the question
what if
i'm pumped this [ __ ] came back around
marvel [ __ ] studios but after 40
seconds of this intro the caffeine wore
off so i'm giving it one sin for the
usual intro credit nonsense and five for
inducing the roller coaster of emotions
i just experienced
time
space
reality it's more than a linear path for
the love of odin bernard is lost in his
[ __ ] again or is it arnold i don't
know i gave up on westworld long before
decided to not give us any satisfying
answers but jeffrey wright has doubled
down on these types of cryptic
characters so i'm giving him a sin i'm
giving hbo a sin and i'm giving
marvelous in respectively it's a prism
of endless possibility
so its ends are parallel its sides are
flat and marvel is definitely going to
use this later to explain away some
[ __ ] when we all try to make sense
of it i am the watcher
this half-hearted attempt to make
rockwell canon in the mcu by suggesting
that somebody's watching me then it's
just coming
he's coming i guess this whole bifrost
space laser elevator through the stairs
wasn't enough to establish which
infinity saga moment we were being
dropped into so bruce banner has to say
this line presumably to the audience
come on big guy time to go green i get
that he's wearing this outfit because he
didn't have any other clothes but i'm
genuinely shocked he couldn't resist the
matching fingerless gloves now i have to
say that this scene does not contain a
breakdance
actual video footage of cinemasins staff
trying to coax a joke out of her sick
mind somehow makes its way into this
episode show wants me to believe the
zombie versions of iron man doctor
strange and wong are somehow more
effective in this fight than they would
be normally i assume it's because
they're hangry i can't believe it that
the walking dead has managed to actually
infect disney yeah me either go you'll
be safe with them with the bug that just
ate the dangerous saliva-filled head of
a zombie no thank you who are you
all that's left well that's just a dumb
superhero name like too many great
catastrophes this one sprang from a
place of love
and hope no one will be seated while the
resident creepy voyeur of the mcu
interrupts the show to deliver
unnecessary exposition and puns
janet van dyne contracted a quantum
virus that corrupted her brain does
throwing the word quantum in front of
virus satiate our bloodlust for
backstory and continuity no this raises
more questions than the time i sprained
my quantum ankle running away from my
brother after punching him in his
quantum balls alas hope van dyne's
long-awaited family reunion was not to
be
i mean technically the family was
reunited it was just violence and
viscera rather than hugs and hummus see
the problem with the hand press to a
steamy pane of glass cliche is that when
the sound is turned down i'm not sure if
this is a death scene or a sex scene or
since it's zombies i guess it could be
both setting scenes on the golden gate
bridge is so overplayed that the
audience couldn't care less about what's
going on here whether it be mutants apes
or zombies it's a loss we're all
prepared for at this point kind of like
ohio because once earth's mightiest
heroes joined the infected
no one else stood a chance
unless of course they knew the rules for
someone that likes to watch he sure does
interrupt a lot you're invited here to
observe not give notes larry why would
experienced adventurers land their plane
on a bridge where they could be easily
surrounded it's almost like the writers
wanted to skip over the avengers using
strategy to handle their flesh-eater
situation so that a walking dead fan
could finally live out their undead
crossover fantasy new york home of the
mets the chrysler building those ladies
from sex in the city picking three
things that would make scott lang say oh
yeah those are in new york i know those
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere the whole make it anywhere
cliche might be a bit of a stretch most
new yorkers get confused by the wilds of
connecticut do i really have to be
wearing this as an adult do you really
have to ask that question i presume
they're talking about the eulogy she
gave for her aunt which is a pretty dark
easter egg to throw in this otherwise
comedic video this web job looks as
structurally sound as the one made by
that spider the scientist dose with lsd
well just when you thought things
couldn't get any worse
we got to go to jersey you know what
[ __ ] you marvel i hate new jersey just
as much as any decent american but that
was completely unprovoked you saved that
for a real threat like ohio all right
everybody it's grand central unless the
show is claiming some butterfly effect
nonsense has rerouted the train lines
you need to go to penn station if you
want to train to new jersey uh splitting
up do you guys just not have horror
movies in wakanda we don't need them we
have american reality shows boom goes
the dynamite all of these [ __ ]
almost die because they couldn't resist
telling peter parker to go [ __ ] himself
no happy you can't be this silly before
you descend into the zombie infested
bowels of grand central station when
earlier you were this serious about a
t-shirt happy a truly unfortunate name
at a time like this parents let this be
a reminder to name your children
something that makes some [ __ ] sense
asking us to believe spidey could gain
traction in his adult footy pajama
costume
all the other avengers have kept their
abilities despite their zombie
transformations then hawkeye misses two
out of three shots he takes at sharon
marvel is definitely playing least
favorites
that was your friend sorry about that
i should be sad but i'm not after
watching falcon in the winter soldier i
can't tell if that was a comedic quip or
if bucky was unpacking some seriously
nuanced feelings about his relationship
with sam show wants me to laugh crying i
will not do it i will
not
there are so many deus ex vestus moments
in this show that i'm pretty sure the
cloak of levitation is the strongest
avenger
whoever made the glass for this subway
needs to be sued for poor craftsmanship
if a brittle zombie can punch through
the manufacturers something up pretty
badly so the list now is one survive to
sue i think you've had enough cap i'm
not gonna send the fact that we see the
avengers get infected in san francisco
earlier and it seems they've all made
their flight back to new york but i am
gonna send the fact that half of them
were at grand central station the exact
moment the normies showed up as if this
was just part of their daily commute
bucky you know how the shield works
shoot the legs
[Music]
i suppose everyone feels really
confident about avoiding zombie saliva
at this point but why would flying
directly into the mouth of the creature
that can turn you into a walking
nightmare be a wise move at any time she
gets what's coming to her is what i'm
saying i guess this is the end of the
line i'm beginning to doubt that
sebastian stan even had to record a
voiceover for the show it's like they
recycled his dialogue from all his other
mcu appearances hope
i think you're in trouble hope exploding
through sharon causes this wound when
all the flying through fools she was
doing earlier didn't leave so much as a
scratch can we really take that risk
it's not risk
it's hope and anyone who's seen a zombie
movie knows that that's the key to
survival actually it's both risky and
hopeful and anyone who's seen zombieland
knows the key to survival is cardio and
twinkies the cardio helps you survive
the twinkies well looks like our drive
cars just got pulled bucky says
something to remind us he was in world
war ii cliche oh come on oh it's not
your fault lying smile
smile for me okay sure use your last
moments to say something that'll really
get up instead of you know figuring out
a way to disarm yourself so you don't
kill everyone with your smallness
largeness why is no one even slightly
concerned about the giant zombie hope is
about to turn into i know what you're
thinking that futurama did it better
what i wouldn't give to get chewed out
by that old grump one last time guy did
it again zombie pun no one thinks it
would be a good idea to inform scott
that his partner and love interest hope
van dyne just died moments ago hey just
let him continue on with the dad jokes
sergeant barnes you will not find
what you're looking for even if we
ignore the super obvious shift in tone
at the end of this statement not a
single one of these schmucks asks a
simple why bucky just saunters off into
the next plot point bucky is looking for
transport and what looks like a morgue
according to these security logs we're
not the first to respond division signal
first rule of hiding the fact that
you've been luring people to their desks
for the purposes of feeding your zombie
girlfriend delete the security logs for
a hyper-intelligent superbot vision is
terrible at subterfuge he's been keeping
him alive to feed his zombie bride alive
and bride don't really rhyme but bucky's
flow had just enough rhythm to make this
freestyle work and to that i say these
characters are not treating this moment
with the appropriate seriousness our
powers are too strong they've resisted
the treatment oh
i must atone for what i have done but i
cannot bring myself to leave her vision
then immediately does leave her by
offing himself also he definitely should
but i don't think he has to atone right
freaking now and i don't care if the
writers think that the power of vision's
row boner is so strong that it can
explain away his motivations for pretty
much everything he's done since captain
america civil war do you think he can
fly this he asks the man who is already
seated in the pilot seat and confidently
pressing buttons context clues spidey
context clues i don't think i can lose
another friend today
so
avenge us here teenager you solve it
phew right at the end they slip in the
mountain of roach crawling zombies
cliche that we all have come to adore
and respect
what
sucky dog kissing brainless dude this
hopeless heartless fat ass bug-eyed
stiff-legged spotty-lip worm-headed sack
of monkey he is
hallelujah
holy sh
go you'll be safe with them we can ride
him and get back to the house in no time
[Music]
do you guys just not have horror movies
in wakanda what do you mean you people
how do you stay so
upbeat
i can charm dogs
gypsy witchcraft and those i can't charm
i can kill with my own hands
you lured innocent people to their
deaths all in the name of love
you could make any story work i once
convinced the woman that i was kevin
koster
what's our fuel gauge reading fuel gauge
29 2900 angle cock's closed handbrake's
knocked off we're gonna have to walk
through
that
nibble my ear for luck